today's quote comes from the zen page
day calendar
um the quote is having no destination
i am never lost and that's by
icky having no destination
i am never lost oh i love icu big fan of
vicky
let me absorb this miles i'm a
world traveler as you know
i know i got to think about it a
different way okay
the quote by icky having no destination
i have never lost
man if that don't ground you
in the present i don't know what else
does sometimes people don't
understand where the they at until
someone points that out
or some intangible thing pops up like
somebody in quicksand
miles you go see those movies and the
stepping quicksand
and then he reaches his hand out for his
friend
to help him out of the quicksand but
then that just keeps
sinking
and they tell you don't wiggle don't
fight that you're going to fight
what else are you going to do i've been
in quicksand before really yeah i
have i've traveled around the world
miles i've been in quicksand
and you shouldn't still mm-hmm so
what's trying to say is this
having no destination but i've never
lost all i'm telling you is this miles
everything starts from a point that's
why i haven't no destination i have
never lost
know why i don't know no better
why
i don't know i'm supposed to be
someplace else right now
know why because i had no
destination doing a spike mouse
what i use this at the metaphor you know
what a couch is
that thing you sit on yes and no
the couch is life moms put on this
anyone should be allowed
to lay on your couch if you see
a couch
as shelter as a through way to get you
back on track
that's what the does how many
times the calls you saying
man my wife threw me out
can i crash on your couch a lot a couch
has given
life to that person it's giving that
person a place
of shelter to sit the still and
think about how the
i'm gonna get back in my own house
how the i'm gonna get back on my
own couch
how the i'm gonna get back in my
bed spooning with my wife
how the do i get back there that
couch has given that person
life it seems a passionate subject for
you have you ever had to crash on
someone's couch
yeah miles but i don't trust
everybody's couch so i bring
a throw or some like that to lay on
it before i lay down on that dirty
you know i mean i don't
know where that couch been at all the
ass has been on that couch
do you do you know the average amount of
assets that been on a couch
the life span of a couch
people understand a couch has the same
lifespan
as the life of a dog you know
that couch in dog years that couch is
like 100 years old miles
that's a 100 years old couch that's an
old couch
you as an old couch that couch
all this hair